Sene you say something about the big
secret that never gets told to anyone
outside of Hollywood is that most films
are Greenland before the final script is
made you know do tell because to a lot
of people that aren't from here or
aren't familiar with the business I
think they'd be sort of shocked to know
that um it's important to remember that
movies and TV shows cost an incredible
amount of money to produce and if
there's nobody to watch it on the
backside or to transact upon it on
iTunes or at a movie theater then
there's not much of a point in doing
that and there's there's an even more
expensive aspect of producing something
which is marketing it and getting it out
in front of people so they know it
exists so that when they're interested
in seeing and ready to buy tickets or
download it behind a paywall and pay
money for it they have the ability to do
it and they're ready to do it right away
so that's the financial end so people in
my position opening from where I'm
working all the way up to top executives
at studios what those people the end
users want to see is really really
important and that's kind of where we're
thinking because if the end users are
interested in seeing it then
international countries would be
interested in also having access to it
and they would be willing to invest
money to have access to it early which
is where the whole presale game kind of
comes into play or you know a TV channel
here in the US if they know their
audience wants something very specific
they will kind of work to have that
produced on their network and they'll
kind of work backwards
you know first finding out what kind of
project that's got to be the types of
people who have to be in it and then
working their way backwards to get to
the point of actually drafting writing
and creating and all that so on the big
scale for these major major productions
at the studio level of a major Network
level that's why they go for things
major franchises or very well-known
books or very well-known media
properties are doing remakes there's
already an audience there they already
kind of have an estimate of how it's
going to be you know get from point A to
point B and that's where the business
side of it really plays it's what is it
how is it going to work where's the
money coming from and who's going to get
paid what to make this whole process
happen that's got to all be figured out
before you really hone in on the right
script most screenwriting books
approach it as you write a story and it
evolves into a movie and this whole
industry doesn't exist with people
twiddling their thumbs waiting for the
right script to drop into their hands it
works the opposite direction which is we
know we need this type of content to be
successful we have certain channels or
certain you know platforms that we have
to cater to with content so that's the
stuff we're going to be looking for as
finished content or we'll go make it
ourselves
that's what marvista did really well in
writing for the greenlight the whole
first chapter is exactly about that idea
we I used to go to can I used to go to
Berlin to the major film festivals I'd
meet with my buyers we would have a
slate of movies that we were going to
pitch and we would see which ones had
traction which ones didn't we had a
reputation for being able to produce or
deliver movies that would get from point
A to point B and be delivered on time
and be quality productions we get the
pre-sales first and then we go back and
say okay write a movie based on the
pre-sales write a movie based on the
poster we invented to sell the pre-sales
that's how it really works content is
developed from the inside out the
occasional one-off to that of the
occasional exclusion is when major
a-list talent who already have a very
well-established career come up with
unique ideas but frankly they can walk
into CAA or a top executives you know
office wherever in town and just say
here's an idea I'm thinking of and it
can be greenlit right on the spot in the
sense that they can do forward with it
you